gentlemen we're live we are officially
live episode number one on one with kai
and adam and tyler's in the back and
david and jorge actually no eric
jorge yeah anyways by the way key
question i think we got we were asking
everybody here let's ask the audience as
well folks what did you weigh when you
were born okay very very important
question because
we're about to reveal
what adam weighed when he was born he
just called his mom right now okay
and we're about to reveal what kai was
born what uh weight and what i weighed
okay
so i say we start off first with
let's go with you first on what you
weighed when you were born adam your
weight when you were born your mom just
said what my mom said dear adam
six pound eight ounce baby adam
six pounds eight ounces yeah just like
uh
ricky bobby were you were you born on
time were you a fully full term 40 weeks
do you know or not i was a full full-on
baby still haven't grown up yet there it
is check this out you guys ready that
aspect has no idea let me let me tell
you a few people that just put two
kilograms eight pounds eight pounds nine
pounds t nick big boy
lloyd gonzalez seven point two four
seven pounds d28 x was ten pounds aaron
kalindo was fifty pounds okay
uh so we have george nine pounds we have
a bunch of big babies here by the way
okay a bunch of ten pounders eleven
pounders seven pounders six pounders kai
what was your weight i was nine pounds
9.2 pounds 9.2 pounds
and i was a 10.2 pound baby in iran
that's the biggest baby in iran that's
got to be the big big baby that's one of
the biggest babies in iran 10.2 well i i
have a reason why you could be holding a
guinness world record without knowing it
there might be a reason why you're so
big people don't know if they're six
four you got about
1500 vitamins in a case right here that
you do every morning so one time one
time i was given a guy asked me a
question recently that i had to tease
him about it uh i was standing next to
my dad the picture with me and the sons
did you see me and the kids i'm standing
with my dad and my boys and you know i'm
taller than my dad
yeah so this guy asked how did you get
so tall okay
it reminded me of a story when i was 25
i was giving a a speech to an audience
of 30 or 40 people
and this lady in her early 70s comes up
to me afterwards she says
sir i've met a lot of middle easterns
and armenians but i've never met
somebody with big features like you big
feet she says why are you so big and her
husband was right next to her and i said
ma'am
in the assyrian and armenian culture i
was breastfed till 18.
so she looks get out of here she says
really i did not know that her husband
says honey he's teasing you there's no
way he was breast ventilated
but she pooped me tell me you kept a
joke right
the guys around me were cracking up she
left that was a talk of town the fact
that pat was breastfed till 18. anyways
but i was not breastfeed till 18 i was
16. so
anyways we got a lot of time cut off we
got a lot of topics to get into i feel
today is going to be like a sneaky good
episode yeah so by the way i heard you
went to a wedding i did go to a wedding
they didn't it's like did you have any
kind of those moments where you're
sitting there saying i'm going to prove
patreon
does the audience know it's here though
i don't think the audience knows first
of all we made a bet this is what the
bet was i said if if adam who is right
now 40 years old and nine months is what
you are right now give or take
i said if he gets married before 43 i'm
gonna fund his old wedding yeah okay 43.
but if he gets married yeah after 43 on
one day he owes me a stefano richie suit
yeah suits again not a lot seven grand
so that's the difference i'm getting
married i want to all y'all to be there
is there is there a two-year minimum
first of all this guy's got plenty of
money to be able to buy this suit he
just doesn't want to buy it for himself
he's been wearing the same outfit for
the last 17 years so you guys know that
save that money i've been breastfed for
the last 17 years just like that
yeah oh my gosh okay but not by the same
mom so for you it's a different system
that you have i've got different moms
out there that are willing to
accommodate certain breastfeeding antics
okay all right so somebody just couldn't
let's health care work caleb caleb gave
you love caleb your body gave you love
okay there we go i don't know if you
told him to do this or not
he said i'll pay 10 grand if you put kai
as co-host for another 20 episodes
straight need a viking on the show to
keep
whatever you did for caleb this weekend
you know say thank you make sure you
send him a text and tell him thank you
let him know okay all right pat how was
your weekend anything special anything
interesting this weekend first of all
didn't you go to certain places i don't
know where did i go tell them i don't
know oh i see where you're going i don't
know a little bit i was out of town
you're a little bit of a slick rick is
what she literally how are you trying to
do no i was that it was an open-ended
question i was at an event with some
political people at uh mar-a-lago we had
a good time we were at the american
first policy institute i was around
those guys seeing how it was
met a lot of valuetainers a lot of
interesting folks a guy named donald was
there i don't know if you heard of him
he was he was there donald i heard
adam's a big fan hardcore he asked about
you of course uh good conversations with
uh uh many different folks who were
there but it was a real moment for this
from this you know i spoke to uh
the most memorable moment
uh spoke to kellyanne conway great
conversation few governors showed up and
they said hey we follow all the content
what you're doing it's extremely
necessary what you're doing one guy
said something very interesting probably
a seven-year-old
uh publicist pr guy from beverly hills
pretty known guy he says you know
uh he comes to me but jen and i are
standing next to each other he says i
gotta tell you he said i put guys like
you in the influencer celebrity world i
said i'm not an influencer i'm not
trying to be one of these social media
he says no no i know there's only about
a handful you guys because you're a guy
that runs businesses and you have
content he says but there's something
very unique about you i said what's that
he said he got brass balls so that was
the most memorable moment of the whole
brass balls that's what he said in front
of my wife and i said babe here we go
and if you if you would have responded
with look i'm unique because i was
breastfed until i was 16. he would have
believed that he would have believed but
i don't want that the the truth to get
out yet i don't want because there will
be stories written about it there's
nobody listening to this no no i mean
the woke mob is going to come after me
and say you should have been
breastfeeding
okay
wait too long are we ready are we ready
can we get in have some fun okay let's
have something with this one here first
of all we got a lot of stories okay
travis scott's story we got to touch on
what happened it's a travesty what
happened it's
i have a lot of thoughts on it i'm sure
you do as well you've been to a lot of
concerts a lot of parties so i'm curious
to your take uh jeff bezos response to
the vital viral clip of lauren sanchez
and leo there was some flirting going on
there so he's got some comments on that
vin diesel is asking dwayne johnson to
return to fast and furious franchise
after feud they had and we'll read what
his commentary was tyler maybe get the
van diesel's post ready on instagram so
i can read it to everybody if it's in
here it's in here if it's not we'll read
it elon musk's asked twitter followers
whether he should sell 24 billion
dollars of tesla stock aaron rodgers
dropped by privia health amid facts
controversy
american trucking industry over 72 000
drivers as biden supply chain crisis
continues they're short 72 000. we'll
talk about how much cash buffett has
right now it's a lot of money uh what
nascar just did they want to cancel
anybody and everybody that's using the
phrase let's go brandon saying that's
their slogan they have a trademark on
that which is insane you are more likely
to divorce if you met your spouse this
way new study fines uh we'll talk about
the infrastructure bill what happened
with pentagon sharply raises estimate of
china's nuclear expansion u.s air force
three star to chinese air force let's
talk
biden energy secretary we'll talk about
that biden's approval rating we'll talk
about that u.s mandates we'll talk about
that and more than anything else bitcoin
and ethereum apparently hit
record-breaking highs yesterday there's
a lot of talk on what's going on there
and what direction things are going but
i said let's get right into it and we'll
let's just go right into the travis
scott story is what we should do okay
all right so it's page one for travis
scott travis scott sued
over predictable and preventable astro
world tragedy a spin story he's been
sued by a concert goer who was injured
during the asteroid tragedy on friday
night which left eight people dead
and 300 more injured in the suit manuel
souza filed the lawsuit against travis
scott himself as an organizer score more
and concert behemoth live nation
claiming the deadly disaster was
predictable and preventable motivation
for profit at expensive constant concert
goers healthy and safety and the
encouragement of violence a second suit
was filed by christine paredes the suit
named
travis scott and drake as defendants and
are accused of negligence it alleges
that drake came on stage alongside
travis scott and helped inside the crowd
and the crowd became chaotic and
stampede began leaving eight dead and
dozens injured kristen paredes severely
injured uh the devastating incident
occurred when a large portion of the
festival 50 000 person crowd attempted
to rush to the front of the stage during
scott's headlining set all at once
resulting in fans crushing each other
and the story continues it's a lot more
than that by the way on how a security
guard was injected uh when he was trying
to help somebody and he passed that they
took him in apparently the needle had
the uh authorities said that they
watched the video interview witness and
review concert protocols to determine
that eight people that have used them
as soon as he jumped off the stage it
was like an energy took over and
everything but there's a story it was
narcan is what was in it right it was
revived by the opioid antidote narcan
and then at the same time travis got
performed for an additional 37 minutes
after that took place so there's a lot
of different things i have some numbers
that i want to share and then i'll get
your thoughts on this because i'm
curious to know what you guys think
about this so here here's the number one
question who is held accountable for
this because this is another one of
those similar situations as what
happened with alec baldwin and he's the
producer if you're the executive
producer you're in charge astroworld
that's his product so you're held
accountable now a few things number one
the
rolling stones experienced this when a
fan died in 1969 at a concert and that
became something that everybody kept
bringing it up bring it up the place
where they did a lot of people said that
it didn't have capacity this place can
fit 200 000 people and there was only 50
000. so it's not like it was a capacity
problem when they say how many people
were working there there was 528 total
officers police officers morning day
shift and night shift 520 total the dash
of people were working overtime and it
had 755 security officers whether that's
high or low that's a lot of people that
they had working there right
fans who were nurses were coming out and
helping out because they didn't have
enough you know people were being
dropped i don't know if you saw that
video with people being dropped and then
on top of that 25 arrests uh you know
you see things like this happening at
concerts but not at this level the part
that's very disturbing is the fact that
after the crowd is screaming you go for
another 37 minutes
did they know did they not know who
knows at this point of the game what are
your thoughts about what happened uh no
obviously it's it's a travesty on that
and there's there's no doubt about it
and we've all seen videos from the crowd
people screaming people saying stop um
i think the the interesting part is
definitely the last part that you
mentioned where they went on for the
show after it was uh declared a mass
casualty uh declaration
and some say like obviously um his his
girlfriend kelly jenner came out and
said obviously we didn't know we didn't
know until afterwards but somebody must
have known and that's i think just a
failure of communication or
why they wouldn't let it go off up the
chain so so that he can find out so they
could stop it and even when i heard
there was an ambulance driving through
the um the crowd as well and like people
were hopping on it like that's just
insane like there's no
sense of reasonable and obviously at
that point you're seeing something's up
like an ambulance just doesn't go
through the crowd for no reason yeah so
so i definitely think that there's a
lack of a lot of failure points there um
i'm on the other side though i don't
think that too much is gonna come out of
the lawsuits i'm sure they'll get some
sort of uh some sort of uh compensation
for it but beyond that i don't see it
being anything big uh i just hope this
could be more of a lesson for for
anything like this in the future as well
well i think there's going to be some
big stuff that's going to happen here
this isn't just one person down this is
a mass casualty event so let me paint a
picture for you uh when's the last time
that you were at at a concert even
remotely this insane
two years ago where was it remotely this
yeah
that's why like you haven't been in a
concert like this
probably in years right yeah okay more
than a decade you've never been to a
travis scott concert or a hip-hop
concert in years
rolling loud anything have you been
anything like this recently uh no okay
so i've been to a bunch of these again
live in downtown miami rolling loud is
here every year i know the co-founders
of rolling loud buddies of mine lived in
my building like i know these people
that put these events on it goes a lot
of work that goes on to these events
i've seen travis scott in concert
probably
three or four times and they've been one
was in okeechobee florida which is sort
of like a
it's a little more of a hit what's the
audience that the three or four you've
been to is at all 50k 25k big numbers no
no no one was at the miami heat arena
which is now
17k exactly wasn't that crazy but i've
been to one event
at rolling loud where he performed that
it gets wild that was just a rolling
line we filmed david when did we film
that june july yeah okay
so here's what you need to know about
travis scott and and for the record he's
probably one of my favorite rappers out
there
and
the reason
why this happened at an event like this
and a performer like this is that he
relishes getting the crowd
hype or as he's literally coined lit
like he's probably the one that has made
it's lit
famous more than everybody now everybody
talks about it's lit it's lit that was
travis scott so the point is this he has
music
and songs and the way that he does his
show
that gets the people
hype like no other so basically what
happened was
you know he's from houston
this was his event it's not like it was
just a random pop in like drake popped
into this event to sing one song they
have a song together called sicko mode
that people literally go sicko mode on
the mayor
the police chief know him personally
again he's from houston
apparently they had a conversation with
him before the event they were like look
we know that crowds in your world go
wild
just just be mindful of that before the
event did you see what happened prior to
the event like the stampede people have
you ever seen anything like that
set the tone
for this event yeah hundreds and
hundreds of people
not just sneaking in
crushing stampeding through gates
competing through security it was insane
apparently
he tweeted before like
um
let's get um let's get raid let's let's
get the i want the ragers i want the
wild people to be here
tiffany our friend tiffany who does
social media she's you know how often
does she get
into these stories she's been
so upset for the last you know days that
i've seen her
she's like i'm so upset at this person
because she's been to events like this
and it's so easy
to
for this something to happen because
here's the deal
the person that holds the mic has the
power the person that holds the mic has
control if you want the crowd to get
crazy wild lit rage
that you can do that that's the power of
the mic there's like this is powerful
what we're talking to on the flip side
if you want the crowd to chill out
back up calm down you can also do that
there's been events like rolling loud
where
there's been a musical guess like asap
rocky this is trending right now where
they've given an example of there's mosh
pits or people going crazy there's you
know getting hyped getting lit and he
goes everybody there's a girl on the
floor stop the show stop the show the
show pauses give it five minutes
get things regrouped
in the middle of all this this is
probably the saddest thing
while people were literally dying
getting stampeded getting run over he
kept performing there's a viral video of
a girl climbing onto the stage yelling
stop the show there's a gentleman right
after her like people were aware of this
so you asked the initial question who's
liable here number one this is a live
nation event that's iheart media they're
gonna have some prices to pay right
travis scott the person that this is
astroworld this is his event there's
going to be some prizes to pay the
promoters the lack of security the crowd
control
eight plus people we don't know people
who are injured eight people have died
okay this is i mean the last event that
i remember something there's people
cardiac arrest i mean cardiac arrest at
a concert especially for young people
people are getting hype man and it's
like this is also
people probably don't want to address
this this is also on the crowd
this is also on the crowd with you know
like i've been in events like this when
the crowd is getting crazy david when we
were filming it rolling loud i said
let's get out of here bro this is
getting a little too wild we had camera
equipment we're remember we said let's
stay towards the back yeah absolutely
people are getting wild so when you have
people on the floor people are being
stampeded but people are
wasted drugged out whatever they are
that's at a festival things like this
happen you have to be aware of your
fellow man and fellow woman and if
there's someone on the ground you can't
just like oh well good luck buddy so
hopefully this is a wake-up call then
when you're out there you're partying
you got to party responsibly but at the
end of the day the person with the mic
is travis scott and he's going to be
held accountable
you have something there
i was trying to send you a file here's
what i did okay you can't get it i
pulled up 11 of the deadliest concert
disasters in recent recent history this
is a november 8th article
uh i don't know if you got that or not
uh
what is that background noise by the way
there's a little bit of static okay 11
of the deadliest yeah deadliest concerts
uh go to it the last concert that i
remember that was this tragic was the
ariana grande that but that was uh
that's the one that's the one click on
that one
click on that one
so let's go down to this
okay astroworld eight
dead out of 50k
rockslide festival in denmark nine
this was in 2020. is that a shooter as
well no
uh nine men were killed at pearl jam
concert will rush to the stage and those
on the front collapsed okay uh okay
number nine uh the who at cincinnati
riverfront in 1979 11 death 11 people
died more than 18 000 tickets were sold
at the who's concert in cincinnati
riverfront and there were only 25 twins
oh my 25 police officers allotted for
the crowd control they're set to begin
at 8 pm but the doors were still closed
at 7 45 when an anxious crowd here in
the who's warm up and mistaking them for
opening numbers search towards the door
general admission seating made up eighty
percent of tickets so okay next one is a
ma wazing festival in morocco 11 died uh
nine day memphis once it was meant to
promote reputation of morocco uh next
one is what love parade germany in
2010-21
[Music]
keep going ghost ship fire oakland uh
california 36 this is in 2016.
uh indiana state fair college stage
collapse so this is a collapse this is a
different instance
56. santika nightclub fire okay that's a
fire in thailand in 2009 100.
station night club fire 100 that's in
rhode island 03. beverly hills super
club fire 165 that's uh
southgate kentucky 1977 and then
chrominone fire
194 but these are different reasons on
what happens so because the first four
are fires so let me let me ask you this
let me ask you this adam how many times
have you gone to a club where you've
seen guys passed out on the side and
they're they're on g or they're drunk
and they're just completely gone right
yeah that's all the time when you go
every time you go out you're gonna see
someone who just is messed up okay for
sure so for the for the people that go
to parties a lot and they see that to
them it's what just another guy that's
that's gone right right i don't think
too many people overthink
that's right where your liquor buddy i
wonder who saw that and is thinking hey
that's what's going on the difference is
nobody's sitting down there's not a
couch there's not like you're sitting by
a lounge area the guy's on the ground
they're stamped stomping over this guy
one girl says i was holding him i was
telling people to stop they couldn't
hear me the place was so loud she's you
know crying in tears saying people
couldn't stop and i remember when he
died he was he died in my arms 20 year
old kid girl is telling these stories so
it's it's tragic what happens the only
thing is when you see something like
this is what can you do to prevent this
okay
so go to preventative measures how do
you prevent these things from happening
again is it more security the bigger
claim was the fact that there was not
enough nurses the biggest fact was that
they cnn interviewed a girl that was
there with her boyfriend who says i
wasn't drunk i was totally fine i was
sober i felt like i was dying i felt
like i was having a heart attack he says
i was in the middle i told my boyfriend
i want to get out of here i can't even
breathe anymore i don't know if you saw
that interview or not and then she says
i go to the back they give me a bottle
of water three people are passed out i
go and check their paws i said that
guy's got to go to the hospital i think
he's dead because he doesn't have a
pulse and she says i'm a nurse they were
calling everybody because they didn't
have enough people that were there so to
me everything is fine the lawsuits are
gonna come out it ain't gonna stop this
is not gonna be pretty for the live
nation or himself i think drake's
probably gonna be left alone because sue
and drake if drake's not an astro world
is he does he own the brand no that's
not his brand right they want to throw
his name in there participating totally
fine he's just doing what he's doing he
was a performer
for one song yeah but at the but travis
scott's going to be held in charge uh
live nation is going to be held
accountable they're trying to hold the
cops accountable i think the chief came
out and talked yesterday says i gave the
numbers incorrectly
he says we are very good at doing these
things he said the media is saying that
we were not prepared for it that is that
is not true we were fully prepared for
this these sorts of things is tragic the
only people that are struggling right
now the most are the parents or the
family that lost so they're trying to
mitigate the situation but it's not a
pretty sight the only thing i think
about what do you do to prevent this in
the future yeah well here here let me
paint a picture for you because again
i've been to multiple festivals like
this sometimes i cover them for
valuetainment sometimes i just go
um
there's more than one stage usually at
these big events
so there's the main stage which i assume
he was performing at at his concert and
then there's going to be maybe another
one or two
you know
uh ancillary stages right they're not
the main stages so what happens is
they'll have different events staggered
throughout so at state the main stage
the astro world stage travis goes on at
9 30. there's another artist over on
that side of the event that goes on at 8
30. there's another event that goes on
over here he's on 8 20. so there's these
staggered events right and basically
what happens is
once the event that you're at let's say
you're listening to
little nauseas over here i'm just
throwing out i'm not even sure he was
there i'm just using an example his set
ends at 8 55. travis scott starts at 9.
everyone's aware as soon as this is over
get your ass to travis scott everyone's
there to see that so the crowd moves
from here and rushes
over here and there's no assigned
seating it's just get in where you fit
in so if you have 50 000 people if let's
say you have 20 000 that are already at
the
travis scott stadium waiting and you've
got another 20 000 rushing over it just
becomes slammed trample moving on so you
ask preventative
i don't know how you prevent 20 000
people from scrambling this way there
needs to be a way of this there's
there's people that this is their job
right crowd control systematic approach
these types of events
but a lot of time it is chaos i've been
there moving from crowd to crowd
remember we went from one stage to the
this was we were at the event where the
baby made those um
and rolling loud those uh homophobic
references we were there we said this is
getting
insane we actually left right before
that but
i don't know how you control twenty
thousand math like think about twenty
thousand people coming into a basketball
game they gotta go through turn styles
they gotta go through security yeah
these are people that are already in
there and just are free to move about
it's it is controlled chaos and if
you're not
head on a swivel awake you know
completely understanding your
surroundings you full-on can get
trampled on and then when everyone's
moving towards the stage because
everyone wants to obviously get as close
as possible to stage if you're at the
front of the the crowd near the stage
i don't know how you're gonna get back
out that way and that's so like you saw
the video of the ambulance trying to get
through
how the hell does an ambulance get
through there and then when you're in
the middle of
travis scott music whether it's sicko
mode or butterfly effect or
goosebumps like the guy's got some
banging music yeah good luck people are
getting wild and now you have an
ambulance coming through you see that
you're jumping on top of the ambulance
you're not thinking
clearly so there's gonna need this this
might reshape how concentrated give me
give me the order of responsibility okay
so you made a very good point number one
whoever is in charge of the concert
controls the point of contact okay live
nation
i don't know if it's live nation it's
number one travis scott to stop and say
guys let's get help for this is he
number one well i don't know if he's
number one
i'd say also a big thing for me would be
some sort of like the management team
like if we think of the vault right
you're the vault you're kind of doing
your thing and you're talking you're in
your own headspace at that point right
you're doing your thing but it should be
somebody behind the scenes who pulls and
says head pat like here's a note or
something like something's going on here
that's for to me that's gonna pull
that's a good point for somebody to
communicate so then the question becomes
did somebody communicate to him to say
hey eight people are down that's it
someone communicates that they did so if
they did apparently they did
yeah if patrick sees an ambulance in the
middle of the crowd i mean you stop it
he clearly saw the ambulance there's no
way you can't see it that's true so he
chose to go so that's to me look i've
ran events as large as 10 000 people at
mgm grand right where you see what's
going on
uh you have to be aware of what's going
on in a big way i remember we do events
and guys would come the night before and
sleep in front 2000 people would be
lined up and planet hotel would say you
guys can't do this anymore and it would
be stampede so we have to slow
everything down because a couple times
people would run and people fell yeah
one guy even bumped into my dad and my
dad almost fell you know security came
and said you know your dad almost fell
so people were running through they
didn't know was your dad
so i think there's a part of that where
crowd control running man that is very
dangerous when you do that that's number
one protocol changing but number two
would be
i don't know man if you're on the stage
and you're seeing this has happened if
you pause and he said guys everybody
pause stop stop stop stop stop boom go
there okay apparently he did say he saw
someone i guess to his left if he was on
stage he said somebody's passed out get
him up whatever yeah
unbeknownst to him it was a lot worse
than when someone passed out you've got
37 minutes for somebody to say dude yes
a person's not breathing no chill out
you mean 37 minutes someone cannot
communicate that to you that's where the
the huge failure is it's understanding i
think here's the bottom line
it's understanding the big picture
ramifications of this event because this
event is going to be here today gone
tomorrow yeah but while you're in the
moment the crowd is hype you're on stage
you're feeling the effect the
performance you got
you know
all the
the
all the feels going on right now i mean
imagine if you're on stage 50 000 people
are chanting your name you're feeling
some type of way right
you have to have the ability to say guys
pause give it five minutes back up
again the person with the mic has the
power and he had the power to stop this
and
unfortunately he didn't well we'll see
what's going to happen because these
things are moving fairly quickly right
now every day you're hearing some
something new about it tmz uh had the
story about the guy getting poked in her
neck yeah the security guard
yeah we're going to see where this is
going to go somebody said somebody said
they were spreading coveted shots and
all this stuff you know there was a lot
of conspiracies that yeah i don't i
don't get all that i mean i've been to
many festivals i think those are just
like ancillary random stuff let's not
forget the main thing is that people
died while have trying to have a good
time this wasn't like a stage that fell
this wasn't a fire
this was people
this is the last thing we need is people
fearing another reason to go to a live
event to be around each other it's like
the last thing you need to have another
thing added to it go ahead tyler well
just real quick you know this reminds me
a lot of black friday on a much bigger
scale like when everybody was rushing in
the door at black friday but that
stopped because you can do online
shopping now so there's been a lot of
talk about the metaverse how long and
does this lead credence to the idea of
people just slap on an oculus and they
go to a live event through their not a
live event but but a concert through
their their virtual reality in the
metaverse they can dress up as their
character this set and the other it's
like does this speed that up at all and
how does this change you know live
events going forward i think that's a
good point but look i think live events
people have been yearning to get the
hell out there and have a good time i
don't see that happening anytime soon
especially with the limited the limited
access we've had to live events like
people are probably craving it more now
than ever but interestingly enough
there's a correlation here too though if
you think about it with uh all the
aggression and sports and view people
have been watching going to live events
in sports and then fights and crowds yes
yes kind of like there might be some
correlation here to uh to crash it's
almost like people haven't been able to
leave the house for the last year and a
half
yeah they don't know how to behave
um
on another note
the the the kardashian jenner clan
they're gonna they're gonna
they're gonna get some haters themselves
no i know i don't know about disney's
they're gonna get a lot of hate because
they were there kendall was there kylie
was there they were in the vip section
they were you know snapchatting doing
insta stories she kindly had a mask on
or yeah i mean look
that's where they should have been i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that
see anything but there's an ambulance in
her instagram story
so like she's like i wasn't aware but
there's an ambulance in her story so
it's like oh yes
but there's a difference between getting
criticism there's a difference between
getting sued there's a difference
between knowing somebody love is no
longer here anymore so there's levels to
the kind of pain you're going to go
through believe me they would gladly
change their exchange exchange their
current uh struggles of being hated on
first or so i feel i feel for the
parents of the
teenagers and 20-something-year-old kids
that said hey mom i'm going out to the
concert all right have fun call me when
you're done and there was no calling i
saw footage of a brother saying my
brother's no longer here with me
together that was ridiculous listening
to this kid crying was so painful
anyways our condolences goes out to the
entire family
of those who lost their loved one at
this concert uh prayers goes out to your
family okay so uh next story uh best
life uh let me see what story i wanna go
to next i wanna go to this story next uh
let's go to buffett story next we'll do
that very brief so buffett warren
buffett
um
page four
buffett's cash pal tops record with
149.2 billion on hand this is the
bloomberg story
uh
he's never had this kind of money in
cash uh surpassing a record set in early
2020 the fresh high came even after
buffett ports more money into buying
back its own stock at 7.6 billion
dollars of repurchases in that period
the third highest tally
since the board changes policy to
buybacks in 2018 buffett has struggled
with a high class problem of having too
much money in berkshire's pockets and
not enough chances
to put that to work in higher returns as
returning assets with no major deal in
recent quarters berkshire hathaway ceo
has currently uh frequently turned to
buybacks as one way to deploy the cash
uh uh the uh
cash how do you pronounce that word adam
d-e-l-u-g-e deluge but even with the
heightened level of buybacks during the
third quarter wasn't enough to keep
berkshire's coffers from swelling so
there's there's criticism from both
sides right now because there's one side
that's saying
you know the whole thing uh when you buy
mutual funds they said if you would have
missed the last 40 best days uh market
days instead of having a 12.8 percent
return you would have been at 6.8 right
okay if you would have missed the top 20
and then they keep giving you these
numbers if you listen if you missed the
five best days of trading you would your
returns are from 12 to 8. he missed a
lot of good days especially yeah with
kovacs he missed a lot of good days a
lot of money was made every time these
guys printed money he lost a lot of
money okay
uh there's a lot of people again we've
talked about this before that's not the
first time we're talking about this
people are that are saying buffett is
losing his touch
uh he is no longer connected with what's
going on today with crypto ethereum
bitcoin
ai technology software the direction
things are going but at the same time
you can never underestimate a buffet
this guy's been around for a long long
time he's not been around for 10 years
not 20 years not 30 years this guy's
been doing this for 60 plus years nearly
70 years he's been doing this okay so
does he know something the rest of the
population doesn't know is he expecting
there to be a massive drop-off for him
to go out there and buy things for sale
i don't know why would you sit on cash
for this long and your name is warren
buffett there's got to be a reason
behind it so speculation is he expecting
a you know a major drop-off we'll see
what's going to happen adam so
how much of this has to do with
stimulus being printed you did a you did
a post the other day about how the money
will flow to the top it always does
and you know because poor people they
just pay their rent or maybe they pay
their bills now they don't know what to
do with the money so they just spend it
so the money flows to the top i know you
have strong feelings on this so
i guess what's your why so how did he
acquire
you're saying that he's been on the
sidelines this entire he's been on the
sidelines for quite a while meaning he
hasn't been he i know he he was he
shorted the he sold his air airline
stock he tended 10 9 he owned the top
four airlines he sold it all if he would
have stayed there that cost him a lot of
money yeah because it 10x when he sold
it at the bottom it 10x since then since
but he's just been in cash this entire
time in cash and you know cash is
accumulating but he's just been in cash
so why would you be in cash and by the
way you know the whole thing when cash
is king cash is not kink okay when
you're broke and you have no money cash
is king when you're worth 100 billion
dollars cash is not king that money's
got to work for you so that cash has not
worked the last 12 months right
it's not inflation
but mathematically mathematically the
more you print money mathematically
everything flows to the top it flows to
you so
what he's doing
the only the only conclusion i have you
know on why he would do such a thing
is
he fully believes something catastrophic
is about to happen to the market i also
think there's one other aspect to that i
think that he has he's such an
old-school investor yeah and the way he
does value investing and doesn't buy
anything that's overpriced it's like he
like kind of like you were saying with
when you were trying to negotiate on a
house in today's market you can't you
simply can't because there's like it's
so chaotic so for him it's like instead
of negotiating i'm gonna wait until it's
undervalued or i can get at a good price
and that opportunity just hasn't been
around so i think between the what's
going on with the economy is such an
anomaly in terms of it's just with
printing the money and like it's so
insane how it dive dove and then went
straight back up again i think that for
him he is more on trends and what's in
the past and these trends don't match
the past and therefore he's he's not a
gambler so he's going to take a step
back i mean he did close his uh his
first investment company during a time
of turbulence where he was like he
basically told the shareholders
i'm giving you back your money you've
received a x amount of return and for me
i don't understand the market and i
don't want to do i don't want to gamble
so yeah here's your money and then he
started back up again a couple years
later when it was more kind of returned
to normalcy so i think there's an
there's an aspect of that too where he's
playing and investing in what he knows
and the market that's currently going on
he simply doesn't know so what i'd like
to see in a situation like this is where
he then
has some of the younger people there who
are in the crypto market who under kind
of are learning and understanding nfts
and giving them a certain
number of the the billions of dollars
and like here here's 10 billion here's
100 billion go play ball go go do
something see what you can make with
this as opposed to just sitting on the
cash and just waiting for it
to catch up or let inflation catch up
i think you bring up a good point with
the value investing that's been his
entire you know mo his entire
career is that he's gonna sit and wait
and wait for the right opportunity he's
not eager to just pump money into the
market for the sake of saying hey i'm
investing so that's the whole concept of
what he's doing he's kind of almost like
an old-school tiger that just sits there
and waits to pounce something that i
think warren buffett and i'm not here to
critique warren buffett at all
but something that i i think he's
probably doing low-key but for whatever
reason it's not in the in the tablets or
the headlines is he does need to empower
some younger people
to manifest what exactly berkshire is
going to look like
when charlie monger who's probably like
125 years old at this point and warren
buffett who's in his mid-90s i would
assume are no longer here calling the
shots there's gonna need to be some you
know whether when i say younger people
can be talking about people in their 60s
they're going to start taking on a
little bit more
risk and putting this capital to work
but that is uh yeah the other thing is
the other thing that's interesting is
that like 90 of his wealth was made in
like 10 investments
coca-cola apple
yeah so so for him it's it's nothing new
that he has long periods of doing
nothing and then short spurts of doing a
lot of buys and stuff like that look the
difference between the world he's in and
an athlete an athlete eventually father
time comes and you say i can no longer
kick it with these young guys right is
there father time as a investor is there
father time for that i don't know about
that i don't know the beauty is dementia
is the only thing right what is father
time when you come it comes down to the
goat of investing if you think about it
so you know
he he is known when you're at that level
you are known to trust your gut instinct
but stuff is changing so quickly today
it's not like it's changing if you were
to look at what's changing quickly in
the history of mankind after the
announcement that zuck made last week
everybody's panicking about how quickly
things are going to change how quickly
things are going to go so but i want to
show you this article can you go to my
twitter account please uh so
just yesterday msnbc at around 3 18
tweets out in a tweet and they change it
immediately they deleted it after the
amount of hate they got they took it
down and they change it go down a little
bit further down go go you'll see it
you'll see it keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going
uh
wait did they take you down okay go to
my facebook account
um
i don't think they took it down maybe go
to my facebook profile
uh i'll try to send this picture over to
you if you
let me see this here okay matter of fact
let me just send it to you in a way for
you to you can air drop it to the
computer which which computer is it uh
macbook pro
macbook here see which one you want to
airdrop it to just go to not this one
here we'll we'll find it here for you
just air drop it to his computer
why is it not popping up
you want to just text it to him anyways
yesterday msnbc comes out with a story
are you doing that or no yeah i'm trying
to say it comes out with a story saying
the fact that uh okay this is the
article keep this article they changed
it to this
are you able to get it two more no i
don't think so
uh
uh uh tyler i'm gonna email it to you
how about this okay because this this is
not gonna make sense if i don't email it
to you and the audience doesn't see this
info
info vitamin
okay
so
this is this is the ultimate gas
lighting type of stuff
um
okay it's sent let me know when you have
it
okay let me know when you have it if you
go to your email
okay click on that open it up
open it up see if you can click on it
for it to open up like for people to see
it
why the inflation we're seeing now is a
good thing that's the title
just open it up just click on it to
no what i'm trying to tell you is click
on it for it to be an image
you'll click on it twice it's not doing
anything okay let me just read it then
let me just read it then
this is go down to show what time this
was go down to show okay 3 18
november 8th yesterday the article says
the following uh the the tweet go a
little higher so they can see the logo
at the top with msnbc msnbc tweets out
why the inflation we're seeing now is a
good thing
okay now you tell me how to help that
makes any sense
why the inflation we're seeing now is a
good thing so don't worry about the
american people it's okay that we're
having inflation
they immediately change the title they
delete this tweet this tweet is deleted
go to the top go to the article that i
sent you would you screenshot it yeah of
course i did so they said how coveted
became the unlikely hero of our
inflation crisis the case were not panic
not painting the inflation we're seeing
now as mystery mysterious disastrous
affliction that's descended on the
economy go a little lower for us to read
the article in regards to inflation
inflation hawks have been telling scary
stories about the impending inflation
ever since the federal reserve slash
interest rates to nearly zero during the
financial crisis of 2008 2000. it's a
message that much of the media has been
happy to spread epitomized by an odd
segment about rising food prices that
cnn ran last week that segment was
supposed to show in the words of a much
mock tweet promoting it how badly
inflation is hitting the middle class
but instead of looking at a typical size
middle class american family it focuses
at texas on a texas family with nine
kids on one that buys 12 gallons of milk
a week in the process that the segments
suck them to succumb to anyways they go
into this whole thing the increase in
food and gas prices that we've seen over
the past eight months is real and
meaningful inflation hawks have been
telling scary stories and impending
inflation over ever since
forever for once they're not making
things up inflation is now running a
little more than five percent driving
largely by energy prices so they
completely changed the article from what
it was before okay because they realized
people were saying what the hell are you
talking about in regards to inflation so
here's the point
the reality of it is people are sitting
on the sidelines today
when they wake up they watch three
different channels for news what are the
three channels they go to for cnn you
got fox cnn and msnbc okay maybe they go
to cbs maybe they go to nbc maybe go to
abc maybe they go with some of the stuff
this is gaslighting at the highest level
to convince people listen this is normal
it's supposed to happen no this is a
byproduct of you constantly printing
money and eventually shit's going to hit
the fan historically we've never had
interest rates as low as we've had for
13 straight years you can't do this and
fake it for this long eventually you
have to get it back up to normal when
they do maybe this is why buffett's
sitting on that much cash yeah i don't
know maybe buff is in there saying
hey but my my thing is when you're
looking at dollar any time the
government and the fed's printing
you definitely don't stay cash that's
the caveat look like you know one of the
biggest fears with baseball cards the
following thing here's what baseball
card collectors will say they'll say
things like um like let's just say the
wayne gretzky psa 10 card right the guy
who sold me the wayne gretzky psa 10
card when he bought it there was only
one wayne gretzky psa 10 card so watch
this when he bought it there was only
one a year after he owned it another
gretzky psa the opt got graded psa 10.
so in his mind he says this car is no
longer worth 540 it's now worth 300 000
dollars yeah his worry was because
there's now two psa tent so he sold me
the card anyways i ended up selling the
car for a couple million dollars but the
point is the the sporting card market
fears
another card getting graded high the
value goes lower yeah suddenly it's
divided by more cards but the point is
the more they're printing the more
they're printing you you supply yeah so
so it's kind of confusing what buffett
is doing there's a bit of it that's uh
confusing but we'll see what's going to
happen with this he's not where's
buffett on your list of people you would
want to interview is he in the top 10
i think
very rarely do you find a guy
that's that smart
that brilliant that much of a genius
who's a comedian
very rarely do you find people like that
he's that fascinating to be that smart
and that funny yeah and that charismatic
and that great of a salesperson you have
to realize
those like look at jeff bezos how funny
is he not at all how charming is he not
too much how charismatic is he not
character to an extent within what his
vision but he's uh outside of that
you're just trying to be nice to the guy
yeah there's nothing about him
amazon account
nothing about him that's charismatic
right
name me a person that that that much of
a genius who's a great salesperson who's
charismatic
who's tough who makes people laugh i
think the only two people i would put in
that category is him and musk
it's very random to find people like
that zuck's not in that category um
these guys are anomalies
salesforce what's his name benny hoff
jack uh benioff is that his first name
yeah
mark bennett that guy's got some swag to
him i want to say
at buffett's level no no i don't know i
don't know i don't know if you would
call buffett swaggy but he's certainly
oh there's got humor there's no way you
don't give buff at swag you got it
you're giving him some buffett's got
swag man well here's what i'll say about
buffett and this is maybe a lesson to
all the grandparents out there
you asked like what could bring him down
dementia all the time or something like
that there's something to be said about
he's not retiring he's kept going he's
not like he's
75 time to retire he's just keeping it
going keeping it moving keeping the mind
sharp and you know they say that when
you retire and you do nothing that's
when the mind starts to go yeah the guy
is as active as ever and it's not like
he's some physical fitness guru the guy
eats mcdonald's every day for breakfast
he's probably could use a few lose a few
pounds but the brain is so freaking
sharp
that that's probably explains why he's
what i'm saying father time there's
certain games you play that father time
doesn't come challenging think about
sports you have a lifespan yeah
challenging part about anything that has
to do with that but the brain yeah
something with this this is 60 years can
you imagine if athletes could have a 60
year career lifespan think about that
because he is essentially an athlete
that's played for 60 70 years i think
the only thing with with brady is like
he has
such a good body but also game awareness
that he's been playing so long and he
understands the way things move and
stuff like that which is possibly why
he's he's having such an advantage he is
and to imagine to do that for another 20
years i mean that's crazy yeah well you
know the we talked about this with
scottie pippen like you need to have a
second act if you're in sports right as
as amazing as your career may go
it's going to be over by age 40 a lot of
times earlier than that
like the oldest is 40. i mean brady the
fact that he's still doing it at 40. he
says he wants to go to 50 by the way
we'll see about that but the point is
i i think warren buffett made 90 of his
money after age 60 something ridiculous
like that
so
whether you use the athlete analogy if
you're an athlete um it's important to
reinvent yourself but if you're going to
be in the investment world in the
business world guys there's no end in
sight a guy reads four hours a day this
is not an arrogant cocky billionaire
you're talking about a guy that's
so humble so like i'm always wanting to
learn and get better this is not a
schlep this is the goat you're talking
about the goat there's only one goat in
the space he's it today okay a lot of
people that want to be the greatest one
of the best the current they're good for
a decade they're good for two decades
i've never heard anybody have a number
one hidden music seven decades yeah i've
never heard anybody the only thing is
when you got the three names right you
got sting you got ray charles and one
other that had a number one hit in four
different decades i think it's only two
or three names that had a number one hit
in four different decades staying great
charles and one of the names gary
kasparov yeah
gary cass robin that's why they're 251
uh months in a row that's insane 250
something months that's in that category
but you're not probably not talking
about bands
it doesn't matter but they may be in
that category but the point is to do it
seven decades yeah it's insane that's
insane okay all right let's talk about
the the story between van diesel and
dwayne johnson uh vendison if you want
to pull up his instagram post asks
dwayne johnson to return to faster and
furious franchise after feud he said
time has come he put this picture up and
i want to read this to you exactly what
he says when diesel has put out a public
request for dwayne johnson to return to
fast and furious the two actors haven't
hidden their ongoing feud after
co-starring in multiple installments of
the franchise together but diesel 54
years old seemed to want to put
their differences behind them in a
sunday instagram post he asked johnson
49 to come back for fast and furious 10
one of the last two films planned in a
much loved series but this is how he
asked for it my little brother dwayne
okay
my little brother duane
the time has come the world awaits the
finale of fast 10 as you know my
children refer to as their uncle duane
in my house there's not a holiday that
goes by that day
and you don't send well wishes but the
time has come legacy awaits i told you
years ago that i was going to fulfill my
promise to pablo i swear that we would
reach and manifest the best fi fast in
the finale and that is 10. uh i say this
out of love but you must show up do not
leave the franchise idol you have a very
important role to play hops can't be
played by no other i hope that you rise
to the occasion i believe is what he
says so uh
you know the public first became aware
of their uh different relationship in
2016 when johnson called that as male
co-stars from the fate of the furies on
instagram writing some con conduct
themselves as stand-up men and true
professionals while others don't the one
that don't are too chicken [ __ ] to do
anything about it anyways candy asses
the jungle cruise star who added that he
and diesel are philosophically two
different people also shot down some of
the co-stars claims about the
relationship including the 2017 comment
to usa today in which he told the outlet
i protected dwayne more than he'll ever
know but he appreciates it uh he knows
he only has one big brother in the film
world and that's me okay thoughts
ego is a hell of a thing man uh
obviously this has to do with ego and
and where you're at in the
in the status sphere
of hollywood
clearly the rock is bigger than vin
diesel these days and this would
actually be a very heartfelt nice
message
with the exception of one word
brother
little brother
listen one of those just a little yeah
hey hey little brother
like
if he would have just said my brother
rock
i got it's the time has come people were
like hell yeah
right
obviously he's appealing to emotion
appealing to legacy appealing to
just everything that uh rising to the
occasion even the the rhetoric that the
world awaits
right um rise to the occasion
the destiny that you know of hobbs like
the relax is a freaking movie i get
there's going to be some fast and
furious people that aren't exactly on
the same page with me here and so it's a
movie relax
but
you know what what does he say here
speaking of ego he only knows he has one
big brother in the world i protected
dwayne more than he'll ever know any uh
but but does he appreciate it
um
i'd like to see what the rock has to
respond to this is he is there's only
one of two ways you can go here right
all in or all out
because he's he's pretty much drawn his
line in the sand he's basically called
him out before basically saying what
we're two philosophically different
people this is not exactly who i want to
be with
um you can either say i hear you brother
i'll be right there i mean i got your
back or hey i'm good the the this ain't
for me i think uh i i was looking into
it and seeing kind of where it started
and how how the beef kind of came about
and from from what i was reading it was
essentially when when he first came into
the first movie
that uh that there was a lot of tough
love because what he what he'd played
earlier
and what they were imagining for the for
the character for the rock of hobbs was
so different from what he'd done
that uh vin diesel was kind of wanted to
have it be more real and be kind of more
because because they were bad they were
going against each other one was the bad
guy and then hobbs was like the cop have
you seen any of the faster furious
movies i've seen the first few yes i
haven't seen the the i think the last
one or two there's ten of them here i
know
have you ever seen any of them seen all
of them they just you have they just get
crazy you've seen all of them i've seen
every single because your kids want to
see them or you want to see i think it's
a great franchise i think it's a great
product they produce a great product i
don't uh dispute the great product that
they have look there's a there's a few
things you got to keep in mind on how
life works okay
uh uh when you're um say say you're
making a million bucks a year
i'm making 100 grand years there a big
difference between the two of us yes
dramatically you're making a hundred
grand a year i'm making minimum wage is
there a big difference between the two
absolutely okay say you're somebody that
is mr uh
olympia and i'm just the guy that's
competing and i'm not even a pro is
there a big difference between the two
of us dramatically say you're a
wrestler for
wwe or whatever you want to call it with
uh mcmahon and i i've already done 20
movies i've been in um
what was that one movie with the uh
broker jt marlin what was that movie
called the stock
i've been in boiler room i've been
saving private ryan i've been in a bunch
of different things i got a bunch of
[ __ ] going on and you come out and you
do a movie where you're playing a uh uh
a gay uh what do you call it uh private
security for vince vaughn that movie
what was that twinkle twinkle remember
that one movie uh uh uh do you know what
i'm talking about or no
you're saying the rock did the rock was
in a movie with vince vaughn that's how
his career got started with i think
andre 3000 wasn't it no no no no the
movie uh how do you guys not know this
movie what folks if you're listening to
this what was the name of that movie
uh i can't believe you guys don't know
this movie this is uh vince vaughn vince
vaughn and um
twinkle twinkle baby
no but what's the name of the movie
though what's the name of the movie
vince vaughn and the rock be cool be
cool that's the name of the movie you've
never seen it maybe i don't know you got
to see it it's funny it's actually a
real funny movie so
so you know you at that point the rock
was known as taking any job he just
wanted to get in okay and he meets with
he meets with his camp and he says i
want to be like will smith except bigger
is what i want to be okay the rock
so now let's go back and see what
happened the last 20 years
you tell me in the last 20 years
if you were to measure
the most charismatic competitive driven
ambitious loved high q score recreating
himself winning in different spaces
cartoon movies franchises name potential
candidate couple hundred million
followers
you tell me who else
has grown the most in the last 20 years
so here's how it happens this has been
diesel this is the rock when they're
competing okay or when they're starting
now when they're starting out the vin
diesel's way ahead so to vin diesel it's
like hey young man i'll teach you little
brother a little bro listen
now here's when diesel yeah here's a
rock it's not even close it's not even
close right okay it's not even close if
you think about it when diesel's gone to
a point that he has one product and that
one product that he's banking on is what
and good for him he's probably gonna end
up being a billionaire because the
franchise that he's running it's a solid
franchise good for him
the rock is multi-dimensional i'm sorry
to be the rock have you ever seen a
picture of rock out of shape
tell me if you've ever seen a picture
with rock out of shape you've seen vin
diesel out of shape though but have you
ever seen the rock out of shape no do
you know how hard that is
do you know how hard that is to stay in
shape for 20 30 40 years do you know how
difficult that is like you you got to
have a season you got to be caught at a
beach in monaco where paparazzi takes a
picture of you and the gut is all the
way out here
there is no picture like that with this
guy he's been determined to go straight
to the top and he's done it especially
considering how much so
many videos movies shooting as well so
here's the point here's the point kids
know the rock moana adults know the rock
wrestling young adults know the rock hip
hop what he just did everyone in the
world knows the rock movies he is the
most recognizable face worldwide 56 or
57 percent of the world knows who the
rock is today that's the most wrecking
he's got one the highest q score if not
the highest q score today ronaldo may be
the only one that's got a higher key
score than he's got but this guy's
actually got an opinion so to me if i'm
the rock i'm sitting there saying
little little brother dude like
you think i'm the guy of 20 years ago
what are you talking about
in rock's eyes in a competitor's eyes
it's like you ain't in my league
if i don't want to do it i don't do it
if i choose to do it i choose to do it
if if rock does fast 10 it's only for
one reason and one reason only you know
what is the only reason the rock will do
fast 10 because he wants to do it he
feels like he's there's only one reason
he will do it only one reason legacy it
is only one reason it's purely for the
fans that's it because the rock is all
about his fans if he does it it's for
one reason it's for the fans he ain't
gonna do it because that letter matter
of fact the way he wrote that actually
would turn me off to want to do it
i would actually be like like let's just
say rock and i are sitting here talking
and says hey pbd what do you think about
what you just said some do it what a
freaking what is that all that's your
approach publicly what do you mean
that's your approach
to that that means if i do it i have to
call you out publicly if you put an
approach like that that shouldn't be the
approach do you realize who i am now do
you realize what i've done in my life
but the rock can't go say that publicly
because everyone's going to say he's
what what an arrogant prick thinking
he's above everybody else now of course
i follow both of them on instagram i
follow when diesel i follow the rock
complete different styles of branding
themselves very different style of
branding themselves okay
you'll typically see
uh ven diesel's posts are one or two
dimensional he's traveling
he's with
the cast he'll post paul walker stories
that's van diesel his posts are very
one-dimensional that's what he does
right
you see the rock
rock puts products rock puts what he's
eating sunday nights how its cheat meals
are rock puts pictures of his kids rock
does shout outs rock will pull up the
car and go to the fans rock will have a
new movie a new business he'll put a
picture of a you know people in the
wrestling world
the rock is so multi-dimensional it's
very very hard to be the rock very very
hard to beat the rock so rock is not
only passive and diesel rocks pass a lot
of different people in different
industries so it's not only a
ven diesel type of a product that we're
talking about anyways um so yeah if he
does it it'll be for the fans i don't
think it's going to be anything more
than that uh and if somebody really
wants to persuade somebody to come back
and want to be part of a movie it's not
a way of doing how should have vin
diesel have approached this knowing that
they've had issues in the past he's
putting it out there for to into the
universe basically saying little brother
you know here's the right it's just
here's the right message
do you think and when diesel's eyes
rocks past them no oh yeah he has to
know
are you sure
whether he's aware of it or or but
that's
i think he's acutely aware that the rock
is bigger than him do you think he's not
in the fast and furious world
specifically it doesn't stand alone it
doesn't matter so here's the here's the
approach the approach is
brother
we've had a fallen out multiple times
okay some of it is real some of it's
exaggerated by the media okay because
they need another story to talk about i
get it you and i both know where the
fallen out was and you know you and i
both know which one is fake which one is
real having said that
from seeing you when i was at the top of
the world and what movies i was making
whether it was x whether it was this
whether it was that and you were coming
up trying to go from wrestling into
movies
many people doubted john what you were
going to do but let's face it you proved
everybody wrong and you're bigger than
everybody else today in hollywood
everybody else in hollywood so proud to
have been in different projects with you
i hope we can set aside all the
challenges that we have and we do this
last one together here for the legacy
that's the approach
if you do that approach rock's gonna be
like okay cool i'm coming there's ways
you you you know you
look have to have the challenges when i
deal with different personalities
and i look at somebody and i'll say
that person keeps attracting problems
everywhere they go okay so for example
you date four girls we talked about
there's two podcasts ago you date four
girls
if the four girls are all four are
problematic it's not the girl buddy it's
you okay
if you tell me your last nine friends
all ripped you off it ain't your nine
friends it's you
okay
if you tell me
you know you're having lunch somewhere
and all five of the guys you're having
lunch with were [ __ ] no you're the
[ __ ] it's not the other way around
okay if if you
go out there and you think all this
stuff is going on as people are against
you it's really you it's not the other
way around so
a personality like that in a situation
like this you have to know how to deal
with a personality like that most people
have no clout to do most people cannot
get their
their their ego out to realize listen
man you're still relaxed homie there's a
lot more people that are doing much
bigger things than you but the rock he's
at the top of his game and he's humble
and he's likeable and he's charismatic
and he's charming and he wants to give
back
very multi-dimensional very very hard to
get a guy like that not saying he's not
demanding not saying he's not going to
be expecting did this tweet or whatever
this was
help or hurt
the chances that he'll be coming
the rock is most likely my
whether he's going to do it or not it's
going to be 100 his choice but the rocks
most likely if he ends up doing it it's
going to be because of his fan i don't i
don't think this helped i think this
hurt because i think there's better ways
of doing it
it's pretty obvious that fast and
furious and vin diesel need the rock
more than he needs that
yeah somebody just tweeted wilberto
rodriguez said the best thing he said
i'd expect kevin hart to call him little
brother yeah not vin diesel
he's right they have their they have
that that's the relationship kevin looks
called the rock
heart to call him little brother because
they always joke at each other
you know that one picture that they have
where kevin is like and then rock is
like real tiny they have that
relationship they have the stories you
can tell they're friends you can tell
they get along nobody in the world would
say venezuelan rock are best friends
nobody in the world would say that okay
anyways we'll see what i have
you know you're doing okay
i'd love to see it but uh look i i agree
with van diesel i think uh have's got to
be played by him can you imagine if john
cena comes and plays hobbs or can you
imagine they go bring another person to
hopkins
was actually in that i know he was i
know he was yeah it's kind of like when
i stopped watching uh uh what was that
one movie transformers when shia labeouf
was no longer in it and what's the
girl's name fox when megan fox and shia
labeouf were no longer in the pro as
much as i loved mark wahlberg and i
still watched it shia labeouf was that
guy and megan fox was that girl okay now
whether megan screwed it up or the
director whatever that's not you know
the story is you connect with those
characters so i agree with vendison in
that area anyways let's go to the next
story that we have here in regards to
dating
uh adam really wanted us to share this
and it was his top story so we're gonna
come through for him
um
you're more likely to divorce if you met
your spouse this way new study says
it's a best life article it's hard to
find love especially the middle global
pandemic but singles
out there should be cautious if they
want their relationship to last
how you first cross paths with your
partner may correlate to how long you
stay together new survey from uk's
marriage foundation ask people who are
or have been married how they find their
first spouse on one increasingly popular
method of dating seem to predict a brief
marriage about around 12 percent of
couples who met online were divorced
within three years of marriage compared
to within eight percent who met through
school six percent met through work
three percent met at a bar or social
outing and two percent met through
friends and family
in the survey 28 of respondents who got
married for the first time in 2017 later
said that they met their spouse online
tied with the other most popular answer
meeting through friends and family
interesting the numbers right there 12
who got a divorce met online
compared to 8 percent through school six
percent through work three percent at a
bar social outing and two percent
through friends and family which means
the highest likelihood of a marriage
working out is through friends and
family yeah no notes making this i'm
gonna come only to you so tell us what
do you think i actually love this story
i don't know i mean tell us why
you would yeah because i'm looking for a
good referral fee right over there
so just to recap this
they they list the top five
uh best odds you have for your
relationship working number five last on
the list is meeting online right because
online it's all a facade you're gonna
put your best pictures up there you're
gonna you know look your best how many
times have that people
seen a girl online and then you meet
them in real person you're like yeah
yikes let me get the hell out of here
but
uh behind that is school or above that
is school
work
at a social uh venue borrow a club but
the number one place to get business or
relationship is a referral hey i've got
someone for you someone that i think
you'd be interested in it's amazing but
it's still the most popular is that
crazy right now the most popular way to
meet
right now
is online
tied with a referral from your friends
and family is that crazy why is that
crazy i i just what do you mean is that
crazy okay are you on any of these
dating sites or no no comment however
um
the
first of all what are you talking about
in his office adam has the five
different dating sites he has a calendar
set up on which one the biggest closing
ratio yes but so on all these databases
numbers in today's world did you mean
people are not going to use dating sites
of course they are yeah of course they
of course are just this i'm surprised
that you were shocked no i'm not shocked
it's more this is how far we've come
since covet is that we all remember a
time where being on a dating site was
kind of weird you're meeting up on the
internet but now it's number one your
longest relationship how did you meet
her not the name how did you meet her
pretty much any girl i've ever met has
been in a bar at a club bar but but but
but i get it but which one was it your
friends longest relationship like have
you had a girl that was your friend's
girlfriend's friend or your friend's
friend a referral yeah a referral that
happens from time to time okay but i'm
asking you your longest relationship no
i met her at a at a bar at club live
okay so that's second how about the
second one
um online online yeah and that lasted
how long two years how about the third
one
uh college college
yeah and college was what you just met
her in college
oh you know but was it friends like was
she a friend of a crew it was a friend
of a crew
yeah so i you know
this kind of makes sense though this
kind of makes sense and you meet
somebody through the internet so what
connections do you have to know the
history of this individual and then
eventually you date 6 12 24 36 months
you're like i really didn't know all
this history of course now everything
comes up out of nowhere i don't know if
i was ready for this versus if you're
dating somebody through a referral and
they ask hey what do you know about this
girl what do you know about this guy you
kind of now know a little bit more and
you have to decide for yourself whether
i'm willing to take that risk or not you
know this guy's been single for this
long this guy's been this this guy's
been that you bring up the word risk
because it's all risk reward it's all
about odds you talked about this when
you when you talked about uh the book
that you recommend hundred and eight one
questions to actually do more questions
before you get engaged it's all about
playing the odds and it's interesting
this is why i think this is it's a it's
a numbers game i mean fifty percent of
all relationships end in divorce those
are marriages yeah that's how many how
many relationships people have before
they get married 10 on average i would
say so 90 of relationships don't work to
begin with so if your relationships and
you want to have a successful
relationship to stay married and be
together with a person it's all odds and
basically the odds are basically saying
the more likely you are to meet online
the less likely your relationship is
going to work so we'll see
how long have been people meeting online
for 10 years maybe yeah dating apps how
what's your experience with these dating
apps kai you're
i think there's two things on this which
again i'm more on pat's camp it's not
surprising i think that with the with
the apps where it's more gamification
where it's more like it's it's
superficial and it's just there's
endless options in a sense i think that
that kind of makes people um
have a more if it gets rough or if it's
challenging and more like ah screw it up
your thumbs bro i'll go find something
oh this guy's swiping hard
and then the other one is in terms of of
um with with the apps i think it it can
start more casual as opposed to like
you're building a solid relationship or
your friends and then you kind of refer
someone or something like that where
it's more in common and then you build
on that i think here it's more it starts
casual and then it kind of just well
folks if you're listening
let's talk to some people who are
married uh so if you're listening to
these folks how many of you
uh if you don't mind putting how you met
your husband okay you have to be married
or wife how you met your husband or wife
and how long you guys have been together
let's see how many people have been
married how's that somebody put we met
online yeah i saw that no not just
somebody few people pull but i'm curious
to know how many people met online
uh and how long they've been
married uh because that does kind of
make sense when you're meeting somebody
it's like quantity
versus quality right if you're if you're
playing the online game you're playing
the quantity game if you think about it
because you know
you don't really get 17 referrals from
your friends okay hey okay so listen i
got excel spreadsheet here's the 17
goals i got all their heights their
degrees their parents they're the type
of person that would deliver something i
would deliver something like that for
you with an excel spreadsheet but
the point is when you're playing this
okay let's take a look at what people
are saying i don't have a girlfriend
what does it say younger sister
work five years i met my wife when i was
nine years old at church okay legit
uh uh 14 years she's a friend
she is a friend's younger sister okay
bar 11 years in march instagram five and
a half years mildred johnson interesting
so that one i'm married for a year and
been with her for four years tinder app
two years through friends ten years
online facebook three years friend of a
friend nine years married the beach good
for you michael holland five years met
wife in high school been married 25
years j dog met wife on myspace
married 12 and a half years first of all
willie says he met in the club married
for 26 years holy moly what club was
that so i had arranged marriage somebody
said that what do you see in a range of
memories uh the seeker 2020. i love that
ten years your conference
what
danielle uh
daniel danyuk met tenures at my
conference okay well daniel i'm glad you
met your wife at my conference
my wife passed away december 19 2019.
someone was like okay
rest in peace nightclub 10 years married
instagram five and a half years so look
at you know kindergarten it's a it's a
different story everybody's got
different stories on how they meet but i
i see the stats and it makes sense to me
so does this kind of change your
strategy though adam does this change
your strategy because
you know maybe you're not asking for
enough referrals
maybe maybe you got to ask i think you
should consider asking your mom for some
referrals here family and friends
i think i still think
um
i'm not shocked that apps are at the top
these days not shocked at all i'm more
just
surprised like how far we've come these
days that apps are the number one way to
meet someone these days it's more wow i
can't believe that but it's very real i
still do think the best opportunity you
have is just meeting someone out how you
doing
you know step to them
and just spit your game have some banter
because you think that's tell me what
your logic is behind i just think
when you meet someone in person
there you're going to see how they act
you're going to see how they carry
themselves you're going to see how they
dance you're going to see how they
interact with others you're going to see
how they treat the staff around them
again the internet you're only going to
put your best pictures online you're
only going to
like there's been a time i've actually
never really met up with like i've been
talked to girls online one time i met
wow this girl's super cute brunette bruh
i like that okay we facetimed i go like
this oh hey she goes oh oh do i do i not
look good i go no no you look you look
you look great i'm just
did not look anything like the picture i
was like i gotta i gotta go and
for a couple days she's like i'm sorry i
didn't have makeup on i was like no it's
cool baby you're great i'm just not
feeling well whatever whatever excuse me
but you're gonna know she's listening
right now it's fine
you're gonna know
when you meet someone out
in public you're gonna know
exactly they're gonna know what they
smell like how they look how they
interact how they wear their outfits
eric's going to obviously judge if they
get a booty or not like you're going to
see what's up online you're not going to
know and you're going to maybe wasting a
lot of time and lots of energy and
something you're not going to be with
you're going to know
like a girl will know within five
seconds of meeting a dude whether she'd
sleep with the guy
you've heard this before right they're
gonna know and then obviously it's on
you not to [ __ ] it up
but a guy is gonna
like a guy will not even go talk to a
girl
if he's not into her like they're not
even going to waste their time hey what
are you wearing that no so some guys are
are less less picky than others but
still i think the best way referrals
okay i'll give you another this i'm
going off of tangier the worst referral
the worst referral is from a girl like a
girlfriend
a girl you dated no no no like a girl a
girl a female friend because they always
hit you with i've got the perfect girl
for you she's so beautiful
she's the best she's the funniest girl
and then you meet the girl you're like
yeah
why are you wasting my time here girls
always hype up their girlfriends have
you not noticed that
they always think that their girlfriend
is the hottest the best the sexiest and
then you're like what the what the hell
was that
they think their friends are hotter than
they are have you not experienced this
no you haven't haven't had that issue
you got to get better referrals listen
it makes sense why you're single so i
what i want you to do is i want you to
stay committed to being single till 43
and one day old i'm gonna get married
after that the right age is like fired
at forty two and three hundred sixty
four the right age is forty five right
forty five ish give or take that's it
i'd like to know from the crowd is the
best way to meet some person is just out
and about and step into them and saying
hey how you doing what the what's the
outcome no the outcome is to find a
person to share your time with their
relationship so share your time with you
wherever you meet a relationship a
potential wife
sure a potential wife yeah of course
whatever gives you more intel and data
and there's a connection okay meaning if
the connection comes first
but i don't disagree on the connection
part but but connection long term that
doesn't keep the marriage together if
it's just connection you need way more
than just a connection part right off
the bat so i agree so to me is the more
people know what kind of girl you're
looking for the more people are working
for you
that's it the more people know what kind
of girl you're looking for
and then you choose i just don't feel or
no problem all good because you have to
feel but if it's coming from somebody
that you've known the history and
everyone's going to bring some kind of
baggage that you're going to have to
build but it's going to be a lot less
baggage than somebody you've never met
before online that do you think they're
going to tell you 80 they're they're bad
eventually the baggage is all going to
show up within five 10 years they're
like who the hell did i marry five ten
years five ten dates not five ten dates
no no you don't no no the real baggage
should takes a few years to show up
oh yeah the real baggage is not going to
come right off the bat so no matter who
you go with it's going to show up okay
she's going to go to somewhere all of a
sudden she's going to be like fricking
i've been dating this guy i've already
met seven x's of his okay what the hell
is this all about that may take two
years in case she's out there with you
and she's gonna have to find out why is
this guy been single all these years she
needs to know that intel but if she
knows it through chris or somebody else
gonna be like well okay that makes sense
then what happened with this guy totally
understand so the more people know what
you're looking for the more people are
working for you can i say since we're on
this relationship you know what i'd
never understand tell me
someone who always hates their ex
you know what i'm talking about i
totally agree i don't understand that i
told you okay i've had girlfriends
before i've had maybe three or four
serious relationships whatever they
didn't work out
i'm i could text or call any of my exes
and be like how are you you know
totally good it didn't work out we're
not together they would only say good
things i don't understand the person i
[ __ ] hate my ex the worst and like
that's every x like you said before
you know if you've been ripped off by
the last 10 people you've done business
it's on you
so i don't understand that like
always hating your ex
right i agree i totally agree i don't
know what that is i don't understand to
show your life without let me tell you
about these six exes i dated who were
absolute freaking waste of time i wanted
to
and that's how the story starts yeah how
was your last girl oh she was how was he
last oh he was at this now some of them
are problematic but for the most part so
anyways going back to this
if a guy
is serious about getting married before
43 years old whoever this guy is
make sure as many people that you
respect know what you're looking for
people that you respect not just anybody
that's just any uber driver who drops
you off okay people that you respect
know what you're looking for and let
them go to work well good luck out there
everybody everyone needs a little luck
on their side exactly i think we know
who's gonna get married uh before anyone
else here over there who eric yeah you
think so
well he's good for him good for him on
where he's at okay
you know
i was really hoping you would
have a little honesty and
open open up the book a little bit you
know you guys i like you you'd like to
keep things close to the vest i get it
but this guy's
he's done he's you've you've used bumble
you've used that i've been on some of
them
nothing serious has come out of it so
okay
is there anything else you know yeah i
think you've got some stories that you
could share but you're holding them back
you're gonna you're gonna talk or you're
gonna be i mean i don't know what
stories he's digging for i think what
he's talking about is your late night
yoga courses that you take
those are amazing yeah great look how
red
right here fantastic okay so let's go to
the next story which is guys
loki got some some internet game
kai does low-key he won't admit it he
won't say ever whoever plays the card of
i don't care yeah is attractive that's
kai's game yeah i don't care is his game
do you want to find out who can care
less kai got your beat yeah kai could
care less and that's attractive to a lot
of people out there okay hopefully a lot
of women out there for him but you know
so let's get right into it let's get
right into it alright so next next one
we got here next one we got here
uh truckers actually no let's go to the
nascar story first
after going woke nascar condemns let's
go brandon chant
threatens to sue
use of slogan with its trademarks this
is a daily wire story nascar president
steve phelps has threatened to sue those
who use the word let's go brandon slogan
on merchandise merchandise featuring a
nascar trademark and has condemned the
use of the slogan claiming that nascar
does not want to be associated with
politics
we will pursue whoever is using the
slogan and get that stuff phelp said
that's not okay it's not okay that
you're using our trademarks illegally
regardless of whether we agree with that
position is i feel for brandon phelps
said i think unfortunately speaks to the
state of where we are as a country we do
not want to associate ourselves with
politics left or right we obviously have
and we've always had as a sport a
tremendous respect for the office of the
president no matter who is sitting okay
so can you imagine how
ludicrous
this is the president of nascar
are you kidding me to say we're gonna
sue those who use the phrase let's go
brandon i i think the way i read it the
way i read it it's different though if
you uh tyler if you look up let's go
brandon merch
you'll see you'll see merch with the
nascar logo on it that i can get
let's go brandon that's not what he's
saying though no no that's not what he's
saying because you see uh okay let me
just delete the merch you mean to tell
me nascar sells a shirt saying let's go
brandon they don't okay but they but
there's companies here you see all these
shirts yeah okay i get this part that
that but that's not what he's talking
about stop stop stop that's not what
he's talking about that's not what he's
talking about he's not talking about you
know the color of the nascar logo he's
saying
politics yeah if you say the usage of
the nascar logo i get it he's saying
let's go brandon what are you talking
about what are you talking about you
can't use a phrase this to me has
everything to do with corporate versus
culture so what do i mean by that
culture wise
this is let's go brandon central good
luck
getting your your fan base to stop
saying let's go brandon like you don't
have to be the smartest uh
sharpest tool in the shed to understand
that they are the let's go brandon
champions of the world
now when you're a nascar audience 100
what percentage of the nas guardians
have you been to nascar races i've been
to one
um what percentage of you think the
nascar audience leans right
75 i would say even higher than that
okay fine okay point it what number do
you think
let's call it 80 20. let's call it 80
20.
they ain't stopping the let's go brandon
that ain't stopping anytime soon and you
know what good for them free speech
maybe america root for brandon all you
want on the other hand the corporate
side of things the sponsor side of
things not hear me out nobody
nobody is more beholden to their
sponsors than nascar every single car
they have has 1500 sponsors littered
across the car every single car has got
corporate sponsor corporate sponsor
corporate sponsorship corporate better
approach what's that you're going to say
anybody that uses the word let's go
brandon we're coming after you what a
moral on
there
with their logo associated this is again
this has everything to do with culture
versus corporate okay
when you're talking trademarks
whether it was let's go brandon or f joe
biden or f trump if you're using
nascar's logo they're basically saying
uh not so fast i think that part he's
one million percent right to use
nascar's name itself that's right
portrayed in the wrong way he's
communicated the wrong way but that's
not what he's saying he's saying
politics if you're using the nascar logo
you must stop if you're not using a
a nascar logo yeah then then he can do
whatever he wants yeah leave it alone i
agree yeah do your thing but i i think
if you asked me which sport
is least likely to go woke
least likely i'd put nascar at the top
of that list
but it just shows that when you bring
i'd put you in corporate you think
you think you think the percentage of
guys on nascar being on the right
is higher than the percentage of people
in nba that are on the left
are you saying players are you saying
fans i think i think the nba is 90 plus
percent left players i agree okay where
drivers and nascar are probably going to
be 75 right
i think it's very even yeah
i think it's
nascar tends to be a little more right a
lot more right for sure i don't disagree
for sure i don't deserve whether that's
80 or 90 who knows i'm sure there's a
poll out there
but secretly i think a lot of nba guys
um
are a little more
middle
than than they would be portrayed
i think during the whole social justice
movement the bubble and everything that
was going out there yeah i think a lot
of people even if they didn't agree with
it were like all right i guess i gotta
be on board with this
the one guy that didn't kneel
or the one guy that um
what do you
exactly and then he broke his knee yeah
that's a rough go the one the one that
what jonathan isaac
his jersey says yeah
yeah but
anyway what's the bottom line here with
this nascar thing you think that they're
just gonna they're not gonna embrace the
let's go brandon on their trading they
shouldn't first of all you should not
they yeah they should not sell anything
nascar saying let's go brandon nascar
shouldn't number one they're not number
two you can't use somebody's logo so
anybody that's selling to use a nascar's
logo yeah absolutely right you can do
whatever you want to do with it but
people using the phrase let's go brandon
they're going to use the phrase you
can't do nothing without a doubt good
luck getting them to stop doing let's
talk about let's talk about the story on
elon musk says he will sell 24 billion a
tesla stock if twitter twitter votes for
it while the world's richest persons
richest people's net worth is reportedly
in the billions of dollars and can
fluctuate by billions of dollars every
month that value is not liquid unless
they were to sell stocks otherwise known
as unrealized gains currently our tax
code and financial systems are built
around the notion that you haven't made
any money until you sell those stocks
and realize the gains this results in
billionaires sometimes seeing their net
worth increase by billions of dollars in
a year and yet not having to pay any
taxes that your tesla ceo elon musk has
argued against taxing those unrealized
gains which makes sense but he has now
taken it to twitter to offer an
alternative he says that if twitter
votes
for it he will sell ten percent of a
stake in tesla which is going to have to
pay
taxes on because he owes
he has a 15 billion dollar tax bill
right now according to and uh
cnnbc combined the state and federal tax
rate it'll be 54.1 percent so the total
tax on his options at the current price
will be 15 billion dollars if you want
to go to his tweet
actually click on it go to it
look at the results of the poll though
what did they say yes yes so what does
this mean yes so he asked this question
yep right
almost 60 40.
almost 60 58 said yes
i support you selling by the way he said
i will abide by the results of this poll
so what does that mean now is he going
to stay true to his word and actually
sell 10 i think so i think so you think
he's going to do that that's why tesla
has been going down the last few days i
mean i think so but i had a question
though on this because i was looking at
it and they said that the um
options uh in the 2012 as a part of the
compensation plan because it doesn't
make a bonus her salary his wealth comes
from stock prices and they said that
they would um the options would expire
in august next year does that mean he
wouldn't get those stock options
options that exactly yeah
saying here the options expire in august
of next year
um yet in order to exercise them musk
has to pay the income tax on the gain
does that mean that he wouldn't receive
them if he doesn't if they expire would
they go back to tesla's um stockholders
yeah but he would activate it he would
exercise the stocks and he would buy him
yeah so he so he buys them so
for him he has courts basically has to
do this anyway so it's either do it now
and be a meme king or do it next but
guess what the move is on doing it this
way guess what the move is on doing it
now people want him to do it so when
that comes back public so this his
strategy on doing it this way is to
prevent the tesla stock of dropping
dramatically so he goes and asks so the
audience says this yeah then he says i
will abide by i'm doing what you asked
me to do i didn't make the decision he
must have known that the audience was
going to vote for you of course he does
there's a part of everyone that's like
do it bro yeah do it yeah especially if
it's like 15 million 10 exactly 15
billion how many
how many votes three and a half million
yeah something that you know people
should understand maybe people don't are
familiar with this you could probably
speak to this is the realized versus
unrealized gains he talks about he says
look i do not take a cash salary or
bonus from anywhere i only have stock
thus the only way for me to pay taxes
personally is to sell
stock you know the billionaires became
way richer this year why because of
their stock
in the stock market right so anyway
thoughts on on taxing that's a lot of
talk about we talked about realized
taxing unrealized gains that's crazy
right it's pathetic it's the dumbest
thing they've ever talked about what do
you mean unrealized gains you know how
tough of a situation you're going to put
people into
it's going to be insane if they do
something like that just the fact that
they're they're talking about it makes
zero sense
just break that down why does it make no
sense
because you haven't made money you know
how they say this guy's worth two
billion dollars he's worth two billion
dollars today pre-tax after tax it's
probably only worth 920 million dollars
did that make sales you're saying no no
the money is not going to come 2 billion
is not going to come to the guy so so
for example elon musk says he's worth
what 300 billion dollars what is elon
musk really worth
elon musk is really if he sold 100 of
what he owns let's just say the shares
most of it is in stock let's just say
that 300 billion dollars is worth say
280 is in stocks 20 billion is something
else what i'm just guesstimating the 280
billion he sells
capital gains he's going to pay what on
that 24 20 so
28 on 280 is what 56 56 minus 280 is
what 234 224 he's worth 224. that's
assuming the stock doesn't drop another
20 percent tomorrow so and then that's
it but that's
so to say this guy's worth this much
he's not worth that much
he is not going to pay taxes
it's paper right there's there's
difference between cash rich and paper
rich paper rich is what that thing is
worth on that day okay so then you sell
you still have to pay their taxes so it
makes no sense to pay unrealized gains
taxes the government
you know everything that's going on with
the well tax and the billionaires taxes
they're talking there's two people at
the top of their list that they're
looking at and they're getting they're
salivating they're looking at bezos and
they're looking at musk and they're
saying we want a piece of that money
these guys have become dude i did a
uh wrong enemy though you're going after
the wrong person well because they can
afford to fight you
and they're going to hire all the best
cpas lawyers
everything else not about that it's not
about that what's it about
so so let me let me ask a question so
for example for example let's just say
um
you know you you create a uh you create
an incentive program
where you make certain things uh uh
legal whatever take a drug that you make
legal okay
i use the cocaine okay i use cocaine and
all of us and i get arrested
hypothetically and i kill myself okay i
chose to do that right okay great but
you made it legal okay you made it legal
for me to get access to it great so
that's the law you made it legal i got
access to it no problem say i'm driving
on an autobahn and the speed limit is
what there is no speed limit in germany
i go 180 miles an hour i hit somebody
that's going 50. okay now you told me
there's no
restrictions on how fast i can go maybe
you ought to put some restrictions on
that right okay so you talk about how
rich a person got how did the person
become rich did he create the laws is he
the one that's creating the tax code is
he the one that created what did he do
wrong what did he do wrong he didn't do
anything wrong he simply went out there
used the current tax code that everybody
else uses and he made money for himself
that's doing something wrong oh but he's
greedy why don't you go create 300
billion in network let's see if you can
do it since you make it look like it's
so easy i dare you to go do a matter of
fact let's put a challenge for you we'll
give you 20 years go see if you can be
worth 300 billion dollars how many
people have done that you're making it
seem like this is a sin on what these
guys are doing stop it
warren buffet is worth 100 or some
billion dollars
what do you who do you know that stay
disciplined in one industry for 60 plus
years 70 plus years you should reward
that there should be an incentive and
rewarding of that so demonizing these
guys is the dumbest thing to do out
there by constantly demonizing what
these guys are doing speaking of buffett
you know he's been very vocal that he
thinks he should pay more taxes why do
you think he says that i'm asking you
why do you think he says that though
pandering why do you think he says that
maybe a maybe he does feel like he
should pay more taxes okay then do go
ahead nobody's forcing you not to do it
go do it a lot of it is he's being he's
choosing no no
well when people say with a giving when
people say stuff like that nobody's
stopping you from sending more tax money
in go send it he
you can't be that naive at them this is
the part that sometimes i wonder and i
sit and i say this guy's adam's a level
of naivete
why does buffett so why don't we do that
why don't we unpack that sure why don't
we unpack that have you ever read
buffett's uh books no what is it called
snowball effect snowball you ever read
his book you ever read his material i've
read i've read some stuff that he's
written a shareholder every year have
you read his relationship with politics
over the years how close he realized he
needed to get to
political people and to understand the
fact that politics are involved and what
he wants to do have you ever studied
okay so
so
how how valuable is it
to
an obama
to get a buffet to say i should pay more
taxes
how much
does a
buffett
say in that in an interview with cnbc or
fox business or cnn or abc or nbc
a week after obama announces raising of
taxes for buffett to say i should pay
more taxes how much does that get the
average person to say exactly what you
just said which is what
well buffett said they should raise my
taxes and maybe you should be okay why
are you not okay with you raising your
taxes he's worth 50 billion at the time
you're not you should be okay if he's
okay it's not how this stuff works the
way these things work is hey what would
you like me to do hey listen here's what
i like to see
i'm having a hard time with xyz we like
to be able to do this i like to see the
administration follow and pass in the
following whatever law whatever
you know policy etc etc great hey can
you do me a favor yeah do you mind going
out there and supporting my tax bill and
saying the fact that people like you
should pay more taxes yeah i'll do that
okay how soon can you do that do you
mind doing it tomorrow can you call one
to press conferences or can you call one
of these guys and write down sure the
next day boom and then obama goes up and
says listen folks a lot of people
complain about taxes but here's the
thing how many guys are richer than
buffett if warren buffett says he should
pay more taxes
maybe you ought to be okay with it as
well because this thing doesn't hurt
anybody else more than it hurts warren
buffett boom you know what he's right
boom the bill gets passed now do i know
100 this happened or not of course i
don't know the 100 whether this happened
or not but when you make it to that
level of wealth you don't give a [ __ ]
about taxes you give a [ __ ] about
regulation it ain't taxes it's
regulation you care about you don't sit
there and say i'd love to save another
two percent in capital gains no no you'd
love to create a new regulation or
deregulate something to help you take
your business to the next level or
eliminate competition that's what's
that's what you're more interested in at
that level again this is speculation if
i'm wrong believe i'm wrong which
direction you think buffett votes
i think buffett uh has voted i know
buffett's voted left and right
throughout his career
uh he's not somebody that's voted only
on the left or only on the right he's
gone both sides but i think uh again
adam i think it changes on how you vote
at that time you're not just voting at
that time based on
uh uh uh
the same thing that an average person
votes fit what votes with at that time
you're voting on who you think you can
get the most things done with
because you're warren buffett
so if you vote for a person that wants
to have nothing to do with you you're
going to get [ __ ] done with that person
so you'd much rather get somebody to get
elected that's willing to work with you
during those four years to help pass
stuff that's going to favor you do you
think you voted for trump ever
i don't know
i don't think about it
i don't think you voted for trump no i
don't think because i don't think sure
he endorsed hillary i don't think a
buffett likes people like trump because
it's not his cup of tea
i don't think buffett is a trump guy
and i don't think trump's a buffett guy
i don't think uh i don't see those two
having dinner together the whole reason
that i brought that up is because
obviously you're talking about taxes and
why
uh
in this case elon musk was not willing
to obviously want to pay more taxes
but
essentially
you have a buffet saying yes we should
pay more and you have a mosque
saying that no i should pay less so
here's my point
they're both concerned about regulation
are they not let me ask you questions
let me ask you a question yeah let me
ask a question between the two you ready
here's a question for you okay which one
of the two does the current
administration like and support
the current administration does not uh
for so for whatever reason get along
with elon musk why do you think they
don't like elon musk i don't know but he
hasn't been invited to any of the well
why do you think why do you think though
why do you think though
why
because he's questioning their their
antics why
because he's a guy he's one no the
people the people who have voted for
biden are also the people that are
trying to get rid of him in terms of
like the car manufacturers the other
companies and stuff like that
and
elon musk because he calls out under
[ __ ]
they cannot stand a guy like elon musk
they cannot stand a guy like that he's a
troublemaker he cause he he shakes and
shakes the system but but he also gets
results so listen there's troublemakers
that don't know
he can understand him and see him for
what he is and be like oh he's elon musk
he's innovation like there's a there's
the risk there's the annoyance with the
reward in terms of progress but with the
with the people that are very structured
and very like proper
let me ask you who's more scared bezos
or elon musk
scared who's more scared of what of the
administration who was more scared i
think uh elon musk no i think jeff bezos
jeff bezos by far but not even close
how how how would you say amazon the way
they're going after amazon the way that
there's more of a monopoly there and i
also think that elon musk is more kind
of like i don't give a [ __ ] type of guy
okay let me ask the question in a
completely different way from you here's
a different way of asking a question
from you you ready
you know the movie gladiator where
russell crowe goes up to
his owner and he says hey you used to be
a gladiator right when you win the crowd
okay you think bezos has won the crowd
no you think uh ila mask has won the
crowd absolutely matter of fact pull up
jeff bezos's twitter account i don't
even know the number i want to say six
million i'm gonna say seven i don't know
the number i wanna say six or seven
million for a guy worth 200 billion
dollars he's only got six or seven
million followers [ __ ] i was off
three million okay now go to elon musk
okay
net worth about the same used to be six
months ago three months ago unless
things change two weeks uh
until things change and last two weeks
just click on elon musk right there
account go back click on the illamasqua
in his account 63 million
that's 21 times
21 times more so you have to know elon
has won the crowd bezos has not
so elon if you go after elon you're
going after 63 million people that are
going to come after they're going to
rally behind if you go after bezos
no one's going to be they're going to be
like listen it is what it is
bezos is scared elon musk is not scared
bezos how often have you heard basos
ruffle the feathers of people in
politics and say something all the time
no bezos oh oh never no how long you how
about
the only time i think i've seen that is
when he's yeah when he's like everyone's
everyone's agreeing with that but it's
popular it's popular it's more hopping
on it because you know the odds are it's
an easy it's an easy win anyways this
leads us into the next story which is
what happened between him and uh
leo at a uh what was it at an event
when there was a picture of the way if
you want to pull up the picture of leo
uh uh and uh his girl what page is some
page two okay jeff bezos response to
viral clip
of lauren sanchez and leo
jokes leo come over here amazon
co-founder 57 years old monday threw
down the playful threat while poking fun
at a video that went viral over the
weekend the clip document in a moment
that he and the partner lauren sanchez
shared with the capri at lacma art and
film gal on la saturday in the brief the
emmy award-winning journalist 51 can be
seen flashing a big smile at the 46 year
old actor a long-time co-chair of the
annual event while bezos stands by her
side leo is mr steele yo girl bar still
sports jokingly said about this uh and
then he says let's come over here i want
to show you something leo and then he
put that with a danger fatal drop sign
so if you want to go back to uh the
danger of fatal drop sign look at that
uh cliff
okay which is funny good for you for
showing sense of humor and by the way
look at those traps
okay guys in shape looking guys
yeah the guy's been working out mr
yogurt who is that what song is that mr
still your girl
all right
thoughts do you have any thoughts yeah
here we go
could leo steal jeff bezos girl
absolutely i'm sure he could bro
freaking leonardo dicaprio do you think
leo is too old for him there you go
you think leo who is what age
46 has any interest whatsoever in lauren
sanchez who's 51 years old or 50
yeah 51 no
zero interest
if there's a number three
she's attractive she's too old for him
if there's a number three in front of a
woman's age leo hang got no interest
ricky gervais said it best what do you
say he said it best when he said
listen
you know the movie uh uh the the
the mob movie that they created
he saw the irishman i watched it good
movie a little too long but i watched it
as a matter of fact the movie is so long
that leonardo dicaprio one with his day
to watch the movie by the time the movie
ended
exactly the girl he's dating right now
camila maroney
is 24 years old makes sense the last
girl he dated today was actually a girl
from miami who i know hung out there a
million times nina agdal she's been on
the cover of sports illustrated she just
turned 29.
so he saw the writing on the wall he's
like listen a little too old for me you
know leo i think abides by the
um
half your age plus seven so he's 46 half
your age 23 plus seven that's 30. that's
too old for him he's like half your age
minus seven is basically where he's at i
said that's illegal right there i think
he just follows the half your age theory
is what he does he follows half the age
theory yeah
if you go back to the video
i see one person wearing a mask in la
and that's the waiter in the background
there by the way do you see james
goldstein in the back he's the guy the
old guy with the hat the long hair yeah
he's at every single nba game in the
yeah yeah that guy's a maid man over
there in the nba
is there a
is there a more eligible bachelor on the
planet than leonardo dicaprio is there
adam sosnick yeah
getting married he's just you know
look look what happened to clooney do
you think you know he basically he went
did his uh
we got five minutes pick a story you got
five minutes you want to go to approval
rating because adam always talks about
approval rating how important go to page
nine go to page nine approval rating
uh okay biden's approval rating
sinks public disapproval higher than
ever before the supposed story results
of a new poll released on sunday show a
further decline tyler may want to pull
up the poll in president biden's
approval rating coupled with a likewise
increase in his disapproval rating the
poll shows biden sits
at a mere 38 approval rating uh while
his disapproval rating shot up to 59 the
poll was conducted at a joint effort of
sue faulk university and usa today which
wrote that it had found that biden's
support had centered at cratered
among the independent voters who
delivered his margin of victory over
former president donald trump a year ago
vice president kamala harris had similar
results from recent polls she is
currently at 51 disapproval rating and
only 28 of those polled approved of the
job she's doing whoa that's very low
crushing it so um first thing that i
thought of when i was reading this is
obviously we were talking about
yesterday when we're preparing how how
reliable of polls what are this what did
that one the other so first thing i went
to was where my head went was
if
do approval ratings matter and what do
they say about the midterms if we read
here second and more importantly the
third paragraph here presidential
proving ratings in recent years have
been a decent indicator of what happens
in midterms in the last four meaning
2006 2010 2014 2018 the incumbent
president's disapproval rating was
higher than his approval and in all four
cases the president's party lost
a sizable block of the house seats uh
and if you scroll down a little bit more
you'll see here just kind of where their
ratings were at so obviously i think
that this is
does it matter on him and what he cares
about i think there's probably an ego
aspect of your approval rating this than
the other when you're in the office but
beyond that it's for me it's the bigger
indicator of what is the country saying
like where where were things going and
if the house flips uh in the midterm
election next year it's going to be very
challenging for him to do anything
as hard as it has been
now when he's had all three houses molly
look at look at the change
so for clinton it was -52
uh parties seats change house midterms
minus 52
clinton plus five on the second term
plus eight bush
minus 30 push obama minus 63.
and on obama minus 13 both times he lost
and then trump was minus 40. so trump's
the third worst between obama
and clinton
and bush and clinton are the only ones
that had a positive on one of the
midterms
wow okay when does uh so bush was how
bad do you think this is going to be
with bible how bad the thing with bush
what do you mean by how bad the flip
oh the house yeah or the the midterms
yes i think they're going to get crushed
like like crushed like worse than obama
crushed minus 63 like that look i can
see that guy i mean he could be the goat
if he does that i don't know about
i don't know about that but uh here
here's what i do know
um
i think
there there might be people out there
they're gonna laugh but that's fine i
think we've seen the worst
of biden
like he just had something to make a
comeback i think he just had something
this week
that's actually going to help him
think about what's happened over the
last six months
number one his not handling covid
has not been effective the way that they
left afghanistan i think short term that
hurt him long term that might help him
long term when he if he runs for
re-election because which i don't even
know if he will uh
afghanistan was a disaster short term
everything that's happened with
inflation with the supply chain not good
obviously joe manchin chris and cinema
getting in the way the let's go brandon
thing i think a lot of the bad stuff has
happened and he's sort of weathered the
storm sort of
but
he needed a win and he just got a win
with this infrastructure bill and i've
been talking about
the need for they've been talking about
the need for an infrastructure bill for
how long
40 freaking years and in my opinion
trump really messed up when he went to
tackle obamacare and healthcare before
the um
before infrastructure but
speaking of net approval so there's a
website called 538 you familiar with
this yeah one we're on okay is this 538
yep all right so net approval how
unpopular is joe biden
net approval
currently he's
minus
nine
minus nine trump minus 18
obama plus nine
george w bush plus
76 for whatever reason people love
george w bush plus 76
bill clinton plus three and a half
george h.w bush plus 37
ronald reagan plus 18. jimmy carter plus
24. this over the last that's over the
last 40 years
all i'm saying is these things are
important and people didn't understand
why trump wouldn't get elected again his
net approval rating was shockingly so so
let me ask you this question one more
time do you think he's going to be the
president become the goat of the most
seats flipping uh i think he's going to
beat obama's record i don't think he's
going to beat him that's a great record
to hold by the way how many seats you
lose catastrophic so let's talk about it
yeah because it's about to happen
will it be more than obama will be less
than no i don't think it will be more
than obama will it be more than uh uh uh
trump
i think it will be so what do you think
the numbers going to be 50
45 that 40 range and a 40 range okay
what do you think do you think it's
going to be 61 63 i'm i'm thinking in
the 50 60 range okay because 60 is a
massive massive number then again by the
way you said something about afghanistan
did you see this speech
you gave like 15 years ago or 10 years
ago you got to hear what he said on the
right way to leave afghanistan okay
stop stop stop stop stop
okay stop okay
go
there's one twitter video up there
that's audio
up up
tyler go up
and then to the left three tabs to the
left there's a bar stool video
okay
kai how does it feel to be on this side
of the equation i love it i love it but
you guys got to see this thing what is
going on here kai
okay go back to while they're working on
this
you can't click i need some victory in
order to win the crowd you talked about
winning the crowd you talked about
gladiator
bind needs some victory
click on media go to the top and click
on media it's the fast
under twitter go all the way to the top
go to media right there okay
okay so then just go down keep going
down uh until you get to the video go go
go it's going to come up here's what
biden said about the right way to leave
afghanistan 10 years ago make it bigger
about what our options are
listen
but
tomorrow the order goes out from the
pres i'm president united states 20
years old
today began to withdraw all american
troops it will take a year to get the
american troops out do you hear me now
that's the truth
it will take a year to get them
physically out
now if you leave all the equipment
behind
you might be able to do it in seven
months
and you leave those billions of dollars
of weapons behind i promise they're
going to be used against your grandchild
and mind someday
positive makes a big difference adam
what do you think about that do you
agree with them
just didn't age well
but here's the thing but here's the
thing on an honest i want you to be
does he not sound presidential here he
did he did he sounds president that's
when he was running in 08 yeah but what
i'm trying to say is he sounds like
listen good for he made sense but so for
him to say
what he said then he did the complete
opposite leaving afghanistan
yeah and you've seen this nowhere in the
media being shared you've not seen this
anywhere in the media being shared david
harris jr shared this and then i posted
on twitter
uh and uh you know you hear a plan that
he knew what was the right thing to do
and they still didn't do what he knew
was the right thing to do just 13 years
ago i don't think he forgot about it i
just how much do you respect joe biden
i uh i don't think it's a respect thing
i don't think he's a number one i've
never said i don't respect a guy i don't
think he's a number one it's that simple
for me i i respect you
i don't know if you would do a better
job running this place than mario
because i don't think you would want to
do that and i think your position of
strength is in a different place just
like when's the last time you saw mario
on the podcast
you almost was on for the 100th when
have you seen mario on the podcast why
not
why not
so so think about it so this is i'm not
this isn't like i'm not a favoritism guy
i'm very much about knowing who's gonna
do good here who's gonna do good there
who's gonna do good here and that's not
his job biden's not meant to be there
period this ain't got nothing to do
whether i like him respect him or don't
respect him it's just not his position
you don't think he should be at the top
is what you're saying i don't think when
he when he was running then that's an
advisor that's a guy that you're like
hey what do you think he was a great vp
i think that's good like when he's
speaking like that he made everything he
said he made sense who would be a better
number one him or his hillary clinton
question it's not hillary's number one
hillary is the number one no question
about it she's not not a number one i
agree with the values and principles but
you think she is she's an absolute
number one she's an absolute number one
obama's the number one obama's a number
trump's the number one trump's the
number one jimmy carter
not a number one not a number not a
number one and adam adam is the number
one to me and hopefully before 43 a
number one for somebody thank you
hopefully a number one for somebody how
does the number such a sweetheart i'd
love to talk to you more i got to go
cause i got a dream team called dreams
really enjoyed it i think we may do
podcast tomorrow instead of thursday
because i'm going to be in la this week
but we will let you know if we do do it
tomorrow you'll see once we post it
having said that have a great tuesday
everybody take care bye-bye
you